sarah mi non hai capito la pietà mai
fatto l'altra volta mi è durata 15
giorni ci sono pure andato al mare
tesoro fi veloce fosse 81 ora devo sale
ricostruzione coloro e scan to be
piegata cosa stavolta la mameli ben i
capelli e che l'altra volta dopo una
settimana erano già forti o proprio voi
adesso che arriva restate facciamo un
bel taglio sì però non più di un
centimetro e mi raccomando come come la
facciamo le pieghe california mai del
mestiere grest ti so come ho fatto io
direi capelli bianchi mi si vedono
subito cioè ho fatto solo tre settimane
fa eco lo sa io ti ricordo sono venuto a
fare lo shampoo è no la doccia nome
bagnare seppi non ti offendere però ti
vogliono ottimo insegnare allora guarda
tu fai così no e poi tiri o cucciolo di
avviso perché dice non si può fare ma
non è vero perché bisogno informata
voglio schiarire senza the color oro
troppo fredda così adesso tocca a
35 euro il colore ma vero farai viso lo
sapevo me lo facevo fare da mio cugino